we are live hello everybody I hope
you're having an amazing Monday so far
it is my turn to share in my online
mastermind group and so I thought I'd
make a quick video about how to get more
subscribers on YouTube and a lot of the
members in my mastermind group have
YouTube channels are trying to build it
up I recently got my silver play button
for 100,000 subscribers on the channel
we actually now have 150,000 past that
yesterday or are they before so i
thought i'd share my 10 ways to get to a
hundred thousand subscribers to help
those of you who are trying to build
your channels up as well so let's get
into it first step first tip is to start
a lot of people this far the most common
challenge for a lot of people they don't
start you know you want it to be perfect
you want to be amazing you don't think
your skills are ready you know you're
afraid of what people might think of you
if you put this up and I think the thing
that you need to keep in mind is you
suck at anything at the start right
anything that you try to learn at the
start anything rock climbing french
cooking youtube we're going to suck at
the start right expect to suck don't
expect to look at some youtubers that
you look up to and be like him or her
immediately right you will suck that's
okay tomorrow do it again you'll suck a
little bit less the next thing you'll
suck a little bit less and then over
time you will start to get good I think
I start to get great right and so don't
have these insanely high expectations of
yourself because I feel like that holds
a lot of people back from actually
starting up their YouTube channel so
just start number two is be consistent
and I think a lot of people who start on
YouTube they started out they don't get
immediate results you don't get feedback
and comments and then they give up and
then they start again later and they
don't get the feedback and comments and
so then they give up and it's always
this kind of start and stop and start
and stop and start and stop and the most
important thing once you start is that
you actually continue to do it that
you're consistent with your schedule i
would say at least at least one video
per week not so much for the audience
not so much because you're training your
audience to come back
once a week it's for you for you to get
better right if you want to get better
at anything then you need to practice
you need to be consistent you have to
set a schedule and make time for it and
make it important right i have 2867
videos on my channel now with this one
2868 a lot of them aren't public a lot
of them are just me practicing but it's
almost three thousand videos right as
you do something three thousand times
hopefully you're going to get better at
it and so I would be consistent at it
even if you're not getting the traction
and the audience in the comments and the
love that you want to get right you're
not getting the views that you look at
these big channels and say well how come
I can't get there you look at your
Avenue or advertising revenue and it's
not coming in yet you need to be
consistent for you to get better for you
to have the skill set so that when you
are producing great content then people
want to come and subscribe to life and
do all those great things right anybody
who was honing their craft you need to
spend the time to get really good at it
so at least once a week if not more just
to beat on your craft to actually get
good and find your style number three is
talk about what's important to you I
think a lot of people their videos and I
watch those videos videos just they
don't have passion they don't have
energy they don't have excitement and
you want to talk about things that mean
something to you right if you see
something on the news that really
bothers you that's when you want to get
on and record it if you are ever in a
moment of heightened emotions whether
it's passion sadness love you know
hatred that's when you want to get on
camera and film because what a lot of
people do too often is they think about
an idea for video I'm so upset about
this I can't believe this has happened
in my life I can't believe these people
exist and then that's a good idea for
video and i'm going to do that next week
I'm going to do that tomorrow and then
you get on camera tomorrow and you suck
right because that vibe that you are in
is gone and so whenever you're feeling
heightened ammo
shins that's when you want to get on
camera and start making a video talk
about the things that mean something to
you show me some passion because you
could say the same the same words right
if I was talking like this and I was
giving you my top 10 ways to make money
and be successful and get subscribers on
YouTube it's really boring right so the
words and the content are important but
equally or more important is how you say
it right the intention the passion
energy the enthusiasm has to be there
for what you're doing so you talked with
things that are important to you number
4 scratch your own itch and by this I
mean create content that you feel is
missing on YouTube right create content
that you would love to be a consumer of
like I wish this was out there and
because I can't find it anywhere I'm
going to create it myself and you think
well YouTube is ginormous it's huge as
tons of creators out there are lots of
people doing really great things
everything has been done well it hasn't
been done right I look at my channel and
you look at some of the videos that have
helped me grow a lot of them around the
in special series in the top 10 series
and those I created out of my own
selfish desire the ants presso one was
to have something in the morning to get
me excited to get me thinking bigger to
get me outside of my usual kind of
environment and comfort zone and have
some thought leader who's done a lot to
make me try to stretch myself and I feel
like I needed that every single morning
to get me motivated and excited and just
pushing myself that little bit harder
and that didn't exist nobody had created
that so I did with the ants wrestle
series the top 10 you know I've been
studying success and modeling successes
name of my channel Malin masters
obviously means a lot to me and I've
been consuming graduation speeches and
interviews and keynote speeches
constantly from all these different
people and try to learn a little bit
from them and see how that might impact
my life in my business and I wish it was
more condensed like if I want to learn
from Les Brown or Tony Robbins or Gary
Vaynerchuk or Donald Trump or Bill Gates
or Steve Jobs or Robert Kiyosaki or
whoever it is I want to learn from
them it's really hard to get that
information you got to sift through a
lot of crappy videos to get to the meat
of what could actually help you and so I
wanted to make that easier right for
myself because I wanted to get that
access faster and so we created the top
10 series and that's really helped even
the new series that i put out called it
vibes that's about music for your for
your day right I have a Productivity
music playlist that helps you be
productive at work we have a creative
music plays help you be creative work a
half a music playlist help you be happy
and so that was out of my own need right
I needed music to help me be productive
at work and so that's why I created it
so scratch her ownage see what you would
like to have in your life you wish these
videos didn't exist if the expresso
series our top 10 series or n 5 series
already existed that would have been
amazing because I wouldn't have to do
all the hard works and Steely hard work
I just want to be a consumer of this
stuff but because it didn't exist I had
to make it so scratch your ownage number
five is build a community and here I
think it's important to one respond to
every comment and I think some youtubes
do a decent job of this if you're just
starting out you have a few subscribers
youtubers tend to do an okay job of this
but then as you start to grow and as you
start to get more comments a lot of
people ignore it easy I give up I
declare comment bankruptcy I cannot keep
up with the comments you know I'm too
busy running my own business whatever I
think is important that people get
recognized and as my comments have grown
right I have I don't know how many
comments in st. young and look it up I'm
gonna look up right now how many
comments do I get on a monthly basis you
know go to my channel go into the
channel how many comments on a regular
basis with my analytics now it's beyond
the point where I can respond to
everybody and I've brought on a team my
wife helps me responde the comments Ivan
who helps me do a lot of the research on
the videos helps me respond to the
comments and they respond from their own
name so it's not you know writing words
for me and they will flag important
comments that they feel like she'd
respond to somebody asked me a question
if somebody has a secure
Shin for the channel they respond and
then let me know about it too so I can
be active in it ok let's look at the
comments almost 9,000 comments that's 28
days let's look at the last month over
9000 comments 9200 comments in the past
30 days that's insane right and as I
grow out my plan is a scale the teams
you'll respond to all the comments so I
think it's really important one to
respond to all the comments on your
channel those people take their time out
of their day to watch your video in to
leave a comment on it show them some
love back right and to try to create
content for them a lot of the early
content on my channel was responding to
questions from people in my audience so
as soon as I had one person ask me a
question I turned that into a video and
then another video and another video and
as you start creating these videos other
people start asking questions right you
should be an expert in whatever it is
that you do you should create content
that helps train people how to get
better at what they do so really focus
on building a community and I think I
get this coming a lot on my channel
where people feel like the comments and
the community on modeling the Masters on
my channel is rare on YouTube is so
positive so uplifting so lack of haters
involved in the channel that people love
coming here and being involved in that
community that's what you want to foster
it starts with you right you look at how
many haters are on YouTube and on
leaving so many negative comments on
people's channels we're able to buck
that trend and create a positive home
for people because it starts at the top
it starts with me if funnels down to my
team and we built the community up along
the way and so that's what I want my
favorite part of the YouTube channel is
you guys in the comments you leave and
knowing that it's having a positive
impact and so you should really care
about the people who are watching videos
number six is collaborations and you
know the fastest way to grow any
business is to partner up and ally
yourself with people who already have
access to your ideal clients whether
it's a youtube channel whether it's just
a regular offline business right find
some money who already is selling to
your target audience and find some way
of working
together with them not an exact
competitor but somebody can form some
kind of alliance with so as I was
building up my channel I did a number of
collaborations Tim Schmoyer I've done a
couple with Daryl ease I did one with a
number of other youtubers some had
bigger audiences some had smaller
audiences I still do collaborations last
week I did one with Aaron who runs a
channel for artists and he came on my
channel talking about how to make profit
from your art and I'm gonna go on his
channel believe this week and basically
you're introduced him to my audience me
to his my channel is way bigger than his
at the moment but it's all love right
and so it's figuring out who else can
you collaborate with who the message is
relevant to that audience because it's
an amazing way to get new traction to
your channel number seven is get
involved on other channels just being a
part of the community so if I wanted to
be in the entrepreneur space right this
space that I know well but if I was
start a new channel I wanted to be known
in the entrepreneur space I would
subscribe to my channel I would
subscribe to gary vaynerchuk channel I
would subscribe to marie forleo channel
I subscribe to entrepreneurs channel to
grant cardones channel I would subscribe
to all the guys who are talking about
entrepreneurship and be involved in the
comments get involved leave feedback
hopefully the person running the channel
recognizes it at some point you know I
can't tell you how many times people
leave comments in my channel and I go
check out their channel and see what
they're all about any we leave comments
on their videos but if the youtuber
isn't that involved in their community
they may not recognize the fact is that
you want to get involved with the
community because there's other people
who are your ideal clients your ideal
viewers your ideal watchers who are also
watching those channels right people who
watch my channel watch Gary Vaynerchuk
watch marie forleo watch entrepreneur
com right I don't see them as my big
competitors I see is all contributing
our own thing to the entrepreneur
ecosystem and if you are leaving
comments on my channel other people who
are already part of my community will
then check out what you're doing
especially be leaving valuable comments
right if you help someone who has a
problem guaranteed that person is going
to want to check out your channel
check out your website see what you're
all about and so if you are just
constantly adding value in the comments
and other people's channels are in
related industries then you're going to
get new interest awareness about your
channel and then it's after your content
right back back to the earlier points is
your content good enough are you
practicing did you start are you
consistent are you getting better
because I've gone to a lot of your
channels and the content is is meant
like you had a shot right you had a shot
i came to your channel i looked at a
video and i didn't subscribe because it
wasn't great enough to validate my time
i wasn't interested enough in it right
so is your content better right you can
have the greatest marketing in the world
but if your content sucks then you're
not going to build your fan base up so
get involved in other channels number
eight is model success look up two
channels that have achieved a lot more
that a style that you really like and
you want to emulate you know i'm in the
entrepreneur space grant cardone is in
the entrepreneur space as an example you
take the two of us we're the same agency
so I know him a little bit better we
have totally different styles right we
have totally different styles we
disagree on a lot of things we both want
to love and help entrepreneurs so that's
our unifying contribution but we have
totally different styles and what you
want to do is find people who style you
like and respect and look up to and see
how can you model what's working for
them and bring it to your video and what
I find a lot of people do in the first
term is they do a direct copy the copy
full out and I've had a ton of people
copy believe i've had people copy the
logo almost exactly right and use
similar font but people use the airplane
I've had people do their own version of
the top ten rules for success or top
five rules for success and people ask me
does that bother you it doesn't bother
me because one it's it's flattery is
people who are who are emulating me and
I love that uh and 2 i'm not worried
about them because you will never have
massive success just by copying somebody
else right like you can't be better than
me at being me it's not possible I am
the best Evan Carmichael
the best at what I do you can't out Evan
me right and so I'm never worried about
that what you have to do is figure out
how can you take pieces what I'm doing
from what all these other people are
doing to make you the best version of
yourself so I'm never worried about
direct copy cats and I love seeing
people who are influenced by what I'm
doing and bring that to their channel so
I do it all the time too I was looking
at my getting into vlogging I've done
some weekend vlogs in kc nice that in my
view is the king of loggers and i love
his style and i subscribe to his channel
and i just love how he introduces topics
how he takes camera angles and I've
modeled some of that and brought that
into my channel and I'm not trying to be
Casey I'm trying to be me and get
influence from kc so be looking at who
are the youtubers that you look up to
that you can emulate and then pull stuff
from them to be the best version of
yourself number nine is constantly
experiment I think one of the great
luxuries of starting your own business
and starting YouTube channel is you get
to do whatever you want right you get to
talk of whatever you want you get to
create whatever you want and at the end
of the day you're rewarded for creating
value the more value you create the more
you're going to get subscribers more
you're going to make more money the more
you're going to have an influence on the
world and have a positive impact what I
find inevitably happens to a lot of
business owners into a lot of youtubers
is you start off on this path of lots of
creativity lots of new ideas lots of
different directions that you're going
to go into then you figure out your
cadence you figure out your rhythm and
you set your schedule say this is what
I'm going to be doing and then you don't
change you stop experimenting and then
things start to get stale I can't tell
you how many entrepreneurs I've met and
how many youtubers I've met who are
bored of what they're doing who feel
stuck who feel like they can't get it to
the next level and you look at well how
much experimenting and changing are you
doing in your business and on your
channel it's like oh well you know this
is what is works this is all I'm doing
they haven't changed anything right you
need to be constantly adding constantly
changing things up i'm still
experimenting with my channel you think
oh you know I've had some success or
150,000 subscribers which is still small
and in the big scheme of things
but I'm still adding new stuff right
based on what I'm excited about where I
want to go what you guys are leaving
feedback on you can't just stick to the
same schedule always because you will
change your interest will change and you
need to change your business and your
channel as you change as a human being
and when there becomes too much of a
disconnect when you're changing you're
growing you're learning all these things
in your channel your business just stays
the same that becomes a growing divide
and you're going to get less and less
excited and you're going to feel more
and more stock more and more frustrated
more and more like you're being held
back and so your business and youtube
channel have to change as you change
constantly experiment and number 10 the
last one is have fun this might sound
kind of fluffy and airy but it's so
important because when you are having
fun it comes across on the channel right
and other people will have fun as well
I'm an investor in a salsa dancing
business and one of the things that I
always tell our instructors at the front
is if you want your students to have fun
you need to have fun you don't need to
be a fake person and trying to entertain
them and trying to get laughs out of
them if you are having fun at the front
then they will have fun as well and that
translates so well into YouTube because
when you are nervous or scared or bored
or frustrated you know on camera that's
going to come across if you're not super
excited with what you're talking about
how do you expect me to get super
excited about what you're talking about
right so have fun right and go into it I
know it can be hard at the start when
you're looking at the camera or if
there's somebody else in the room it can
be really hard to have fun and be
yourself and again it comes from
practice from experience and more you do
it over and over and over and over again
you'll get more comfortable you'll
become the best version of yourself you
go back on my channel you go back to the
first videos I don't look like I'm happy
to top button right I am not having fun
on those videos it's super blind it's
super serious the points are still valid
a lot of the points that I'm talking
about are still relevant now I still
sane a lot of the same stuff but I see
it now with a lot more passion lot more
energy a lot more fun because I'm having
fun like i'm doing this video right now
because I'm having
fun doing it right and hopefully you
might have smelled a couple times I was
talking and so have fun with your
channel have fun when you get in front
of the camera let a little bit of
yourself out each time and you'll find
that people connected that a lot better
so summery top 10 points 1 start to be
consistent 3 talk about what's actually
important to you or scratch your own
itch 5 build a community 6 collaboration
7 get involved in other people's
channels 8 model success 9 constantly
experiment 10 have fun i'm going to list
the points down in the in the
description as well this video again i
made for the mastermind group if you are
interested in checking out at the
mastermind group we have a weekly
connection time and you can check it out
i have a link in the description to more
about the mastermind i want to quickly
check in as a live feed i know a lot of
you guys are watching live so i want to
check in and see what the comments are
all about new future builder right on
with number three did that yesterday
love a bro and you see new future build
is a great example this guy has been on
the channel leaving comments every day
he's over a hundred days in a row
leaving comments and i've checked out
his channel and i've commented on videos
right so the more involved you are the
more people are going to check you out
and want to know more about you Daniel
hi Evan thanks for it i'll appreciate
the love Daniel Oh TV networks good
point thank you sir ashish it's amazing
on the answer is almost all comments we
do and it's important mohamed nice thank
you bro two thousand bucks how do you
get payment people to comment more one
have a content that people want to
comment on right have comment worthy
content and i would really self-evaluate
and look at your stuff and say hey if
you saw this on another person's channel
would you actually comment on it right
maybe not so take a hard look in the
mirror and to you can ask for comments
what i find really helpful is on a lot
of my videos i'll ask the question of
the day and people then answer that
question in the comments below for the
top 10 series i'll ask people one who
they want me to profile next and so that
inspires you to leave comments and also
ask them from the 10 points
that we're seeing here which one did you
like the most which one resonated the
most to you which one had you know hit
you here really hard and I find that
that helps so ask questions and have
something that is worth commenting on
Muhammad Muhammad Ali's top 10 routes
for success it's coming out it's coming
out Muhammad Ali's top 10 rules is
coming out this week it's been an insane
project I've been back with my team so
many times they know it's not good
enough not good not good enough my team
wants to kill me on this one but he's
such an icon and such a legend that I
feel like it has to be done right so yes
it's coming in how much time do I put
into YouTube a good question that Jeff
how much time I haven't tracked it
wednesday is my filming day so we have
three videos that come out every single
day and I try to record almost all of
them on on Wednesdays that's my
afternoon basically preparing for that I
spend little time every day looking at
the channel I check out the analytics I
think every single day see how the
numbers are see what videos are doing
well see some of the comments that are
coming in I checking in the comments
every single day so I would stay I
probably spend one to two hours a day
plus wednesday afternoon filming and
then when I'm doing the research
reviewing the research on my team that
that can take that can take anywhere
from one hour per top 10 entrepreneur
two to eight nine ten hours depending on
how hard it is to find clips for I used
to 50 cent example before we do the top
10 rules on 50 cent and my team you know
made something I wasn't fully happy with
it and I felt like ah that clip is okay
what doesn't move me and I spent we
spent eight hours basically on this clip
on that video and when I got released 50
cent actually shared and he put on his
Facebook page you put on this Twitter
account and you know would he have done
that if we didn't put in that extra love
if we just threw a bunch of clips
together without really thinking about
it would 50 have wanted to share it
maybe but probably not and so
I put an insane amount of time in on
those clips just to make something that
I'm proud of and hopefully other people
will enjoy me product to uh what else
ashish ever knows requests viewers to
comment yet bastrop beats gary vee woot
woot I'm a big Gary be fan I think of
all the business guys he's the only one
that I subscribe to and I learned some
things from and I get energy from and
for those of you don't know bass drops
beat he's got some insane epic music
tracks that we're going to be featuring
I believe in an upcoming video him and
junior has been working on something so
you could check him out too what else
what else what else ah new future bill
of the grant cardone the mysterious
agency competitor you're always
mentioning no comment no comment there
in your future builder aah bass drop
beats love number 10 is extremely easy
to forget whenever you're in the midst
of the grind yeah number ten was have
fun you got to have fun with what you're
doing in your channel it shows my name
it shows new feature builder with you
and having fun it can take a while to
truly enjoy it too having way more fun
now than it did two years ago yeah it's
true like it takes a while to get
comfortable in front of the camera I
used to have to have somebody come in
and focus the camera for me and then
leave the room because they didn't have
auto focus because I couldn't do it I
wasn't myself with them there and now I
don't care who's in the room it doesn't
make a difference for me but it does
take a lot of time to practice and build
up and I think though the way to get
there faster is the intention of having
fun like if you go in thinking I want to
have fun today while I shoot this video
then you will automatically have more
fun I think for me it was never an
intention i was just thinking okay i
want to answer this person's question or
okay i want to make a video well
marketing or okay i'm going to make a
video about YouTube and there's always
that desire to help somebody but it
wasn't the intention of having fun as
well I think if you just think about
that say I'm gonna have fun on this
video then you automatically will have
way more fun than you did in the last
video what else Daniel hello from Brazil
I always see you here I appreciate the
love day
what else what else what else a bunch of
thank yous thank yous ash thanks for the
tip started YouTube last week started
YouTube last week ash love it needed to
hear these tips keep them coming awesome
Jeff can i send you some of my music
Jeff semi music let's see what you got
this is how collaboration start by
starting by asking by being involved
Josh Jeff hit me up I you know once his
video goes live shoot me a message and
you can either leave in the comments cuz
you leave the comment here it's going to
disappear not going to see it there's
some weird thing about google hangouts
or you can't see the live comments
anymore so after comes out leave it
below or shoot me a message and we'll
find a way i'm looking forward to hear
your music you got you got an
opportunity music better rock i'm
excited for it bastrop beats thanks for
the love alright love you guys thanks
for the comments thanks to the feedback
hopefully this helps you grow your
YouTube channel and to the mastermind is
watching this follow those ten steps I
will see you next week for another
mastermind session and for those of you
listening excited about mastermind you
check it out in the link below have a
great week guys I'll see you soon